مساء الخير يعني اه حروب الرابع اللي
بنسمع عنها كثير وبكثافه في الاعلام في
السنوات الاخيره عشان نفهم يعني بالجيل
الرابع لازم تفهم ايه هي حروب الاول
والثاني والثالث المستوى الشخصي انا علشان
تفهم هذا الكلام فضلت اننا هذه الاسئله
الى الى تيار هشام الحلم ليس فقط باعتباره
ولا عسكريا ولكن لانه اعد رساله الدكتوراه
موضوعها هو حروب الجيل الرابع
وفي هذه الرساله الرساله شرح واف للتاريخ
فكره الجيل الرابع والاجيال التي سبقتها
من الحروب قصه طويله ومتشعبه اسهل البدايه
ليها ربما بالنسبه لا يمكن تكون سنه الف
وتسعمائه تسعه وثمانين في السنه دي في اه
م فكر استراتيجي اسمه ويليام امريكي
ومجموعه من زملائه عملوا تصنيف الحروق
واللي بيعملوا تصنيف للحروب كبير واحد من
هذه التصنيفات نصنف الحوض الى اربعه اجيال
من الاول التالي ذلك ثم كلمه جديده على
العلوم العسكريه وقتها هي كلمه الجيل
الرابع او الفرصه جمال
طيب قبل ما تتكلم اي هي الفرصه جنيفير او
حروب الجيل الرابع
نرجع لل سيد ويليام
في الكل الاول ازاي وفين وفق ايه الدين
الاولاني بدؤوا من سنه
1648 يعني جيل الاول في الحروب الحديثه
يشاء من فجر التاريخ في الحروب الحديثه او
الجيل بدا من سنه الف وسته ثمانيه واربعين
والسنه
السنه اللي شهدت توقيع معاهده واسط فيه
معارضه واحده مهمه جدا يكون المهتمين
بدراسه النظم السياسيه
لانه بعد هذا التاريخ فكره الدوله القوميه
الحديثه زي ما بنعرف الوقت امريكا ومصر
والمغرب والسعوديه والكويت الى اخره قبل
كده كان احنا كان عندنا اما امبراطوريات
اماره اقطاعيه الى اخره ابدا من هذا
التاريخ كانت الحروب بدور وما بين جيوش
واضحه المعالم تملكها دول كامله السياده
زي ما بيقول الدكتور هشام الجيل الثاني من
الحروب بدا مع الحرب العالميه الاولى
والفرق الوحيد بينها وبين الحرب العالميه
الاولى هو تطور قدره على انتاج لايران في
الحرب العالميه الاولى في الحرب الجيل
الاول اللي هو الف وتسعمائه وثمانيه
واربعين لغايه الف وتسعمائه واربعطاشر كان
الفرق في الجيل الاول انه النيران مرتبطه
ببندقيه بدائيه الى حد كبير في الجيل
التالي من الحروب كميه او ال التطور
السلاح ساعد المحاربين على انتاج قوه اكبر
من النيران
الدين الثانيه تطور الى الجيل الثالث في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه مع تكتيكات الجيش
الالماني اللي قالت ان كل انا انا بقى
عندى وسائل وقدره اكبر على انتاج النيران
والتحرك بهذه ال الادوات يعني ما عندي
طيران عسكري عندي الدبابات اسرع عند
مدرعات اسرع يبقى ما فيش داعي انا افضل
احارب عدوه على خط الجبهه كانت الديلي
الاول والجيل الثاني دائما الحروب وتبقي
بيوت متقبله على خط الجبهه وما قبله على
خط الجبهه لانه مدى ايران قصير مضطر انه
اللي 27 والاثنين يحفروا نادي عشان يحملون
يستهدفوا بعض بالنيران في الجيل الثالث
اصبح انه طيران عسكري وعنده مدرعات سريعه
وعربيات سريعا وبالتالي عندهم قدره انه ما
يخربش العدو بس على الك انها لم نقل يلتف
حول خطوط العدو ويضرب خطوط امداده
ومواصلاته ويعزل الجامعه وبالتالي الجبهه
كدا كدا تسقط في مصر في الاديان الثلاث
هذه
الاول والثاني والثالث الفرق الوحيد هو
تطور التكنولوجي يعني انت قرنا انتقلنا في
الاول من المال دور اللي هو القوه البشريه
العسكريه اللي معايا الى الخير هو اللي
فيه الكيل الاول قدره اكبر على اطلاق
ايران من التابع مثلا الى المحور القدره
على المناوره بال ايران في مسرح العمليات
او خلف خطوط العدو هذه الاجيال ثلاثه لكن
المشترك هو ان الاجيال الثلاثه من الحروب
كانت تتم ما بين جيوش واضحه المعالم
تملك دول كامله السياده الجيل الرابع
اختلف عن هذه الاجيال الجيل الرابع
عشان نفهم الجيل الرابع وهو اللي هو
يستهدف المدنيين وليس القوات المسلحه نفهم
تقسيمه المجتمع والدوله بالنسبه للعسكريين
عشان نفهم تاثيرها بالنسبه للعسكريين لازم
نفهمها الاول ت اسمتها بالنسبه للعلوم
السياسيه في العلوم السياسيه الدوله تقسم
الى او تعريف الدوله هي اقليم ويسكنه شعر
ويحكم نظام سياسي باعتراف دولي بالنسبه
للعسكريين او للقاده القاء الجنرالات يعني
باسم والدوله المستهدفه اثناء الحرب الى
جزئيا قوات مسلحه وقطاع مدني اذا تدرب
القوات المسلحه يسقط القطاع المدني بمعنى
ما يضطر يستسلم واذا سقط الموقف ال
المجتمع المدني والنهار كل القطاعات
المدنيين اكيد القوات المسلحه سوف تنهار
بالطبع الدين الاول والثاني والثالث كان
القاسم المشترك في
الدوله بتحاول تستهدف القوات المسلحه
للدوله المستهدف تضرب القوات المسلحه
الاول وبعدما تدرب القوات المسلحه تبتدي
الحقائق الهدف اللى هى عاوزاه يعني الهدف
المبدئي هو ضرب القوات المسلحه علشان بعد
ضرب يحقق الهدف اللي من اجله الحرب احتلال
الارض الحصول على مور الطبيعي في الحرب
الجيل الرابع هو ما يستهدف القوات المسلحه
ويستهدف اقتطاعات ان يوصل الى نفس النتيجه
بتكاليف اقل يعني بدل ما ادرك القوات
المسلحه انا اضرب القطاع المدني للمغرب في
القوات المسلحه لاكثر من سبب اولا هي
اصبحت مكلفه جدا مكلفه في الاقتصاد يعني
تكلفه الحروب
استخدام الاسلحه مكلف جدا نسبه المخاطره
عاليه بالنسبه للجنود اللي انت اللي بشان
الحرب في خسائر في الارواح وارده الامر
الثالث وفقا لل دكتور هشام ومن وجهه نظره
انه حرب ثلاثه وسبعين بين ال بين العرب
بقياده مصر واسرائيل كانت مؤثره جدا في
على او مؤثره جدا بالنسبه ل اه
الاستراتيجيين العسكريين شافوا لديك
المثال مهم جدا ان دوله عندها امكانيات
قليله قدرت تتفوق على دوله عندها امكانيات
اكبر بكثير اللي هي اسرائيل وبالتالي
استقر لدى بعض المنظرين انه حتى لما يكون
دوله متفوقه تفوق كاس على خصص مش بالضروره
تحقق النصر بل ممكن كمان تخسر كما خسرت
اسرائيل في حرب 73
يبقى الاسلم ان احنا نرجع الى حروب الكلام
وهي استهداف القطاع المدني بعيدا عن
القوات المسلحه للعدو هذا تم استخدامه في
اي حرب تم استخدامه وال مثل الشهير
الاتحاد السوفياتي لم انهار الاتحاد
السوفياتي
لان الغرب اعتمد الى حد كبير على تكتيكات
الجيل الرابع انهار الاتحاد السوفياتي رغم
قوه قواته المسلحه ضخمه جدا وامتلاك لسلاح
نووي وانها دون ان تطلق عليها امريكا
طلقات رصاص واحده طيب ازاي بيتم استهداف
القطاع المدني الدكتور اشرف محدد خمس اه
يعني عناصر يتم من خلالها او خمس اليات
يتم من خلالها استخدام استهداف القطاع
المدني هذه الوسائل الخمسه او العناصر
الخمسه هي الارهاب والعمليات النفسيه
والحشد في الشارع ومنظمات المجتمع المدني
ووضع الدوله المستهدفه
الارهاب في الجيل الرابع يختلف عن الارهاب
التقليدي في عده امور منها انه هذا
الارهاب الارهاب اللي هو ال هذا الدين
الرابع يحظى بدعم من اجهزه مخابرات الدول
وبنقدر بسهوله من قدرتها على التحرك
بالصوره باعداد كبيره مش بس داخل اقليم
دوله او داخل اراضي دوله التي يتحرر
بسهوله عبر حدود الدول وباعداد بنشوف انه
يحصل على تسليح لا يتوفر الا للبيوت زي
الالغام البحريه والالغام المضاده
للدبابات
والبروز او الطائرات المسيره وعنده قدره
على الحصول على معلومات على تحركات
الاجهزه الامنيه والجيوش في الدوله
المستهدفه في كل الاحوال هذا الارهاب
يختلف ايضا عن الارهاب القديم في انه هو ب
يسعى الاحتلال الارض ما فيش اي مع ارهابيه
في التاريخ كانت تسعى يعني بشكل واضح ربما
استثناءات قليله انه يحتل الارض كان بيسعى
الارهاب المجتمع انه يقتل الشخصيات اللي
بيع ارضها اما الارهاب الحديث معظم هذه
الجماعات الهدف الاساسي انه يخلي سكان
منطقه معينه ويقيم عليها دوله دور فعليها
عالمه وبندي مقدمه لتفتيت الدوله
المستهدفه واقسامها طيب ما حصل مثلا داعش
عملت في العراق وفي سوريا الارهاب طبعا
الارهاب لما بيستهدف القطاع المدني هو
الهدف كله انه يحل القطاع المدني فليش
للسياحه وليس استثمارات ولم نستخرج للشغل
ولا التلاميذ الخروج للمدارس وبالتالي
القطاع المدني وبالتالي يتم تقويه الدوله
وتسقط بعيدا عن القوات المسلحه العنصر
الثاني هو استخدام العمليات النفسيه
والعمليات النفسيه اللي في الجيل الرابع
المنشورات في الحروب القديمه في الحروب
القديمه كانت الجيش بيطلعوا يرمي من
الطياره بتاعتو منشورات على العسكريين
تدعوهم الى الياس والاستسلام في الحروب
الحديثه من يستخدم في الكلام ده ويستهدف
القطاع المدني والعسكريين ايضا بدايه سيئه
جدا او سلبيه جدا وفي احداث خطوات اقلاع
وتغيير وتاثيره الاقناع هناك في وضع سيئ
وان اليوم اه اسود الغضب اكثر سوادا وان
دولتك لن تستطيع ان توفر لك الحياه افضل
وبالتالي يجب التغيير عشان يعمل التغيير
لازم ينزل الى الشارع ولما نزل الى الشارع
عشان يعمل التغيير اللي عمله حياه افضل
ابتدى هذا العدو انه يخطف هذا الحد او
الناس المطالبين بالتغيير الى اجندته
الخاصه الامثله طبعا كثيرا بينزلوا لمطالب
مشروعه جدا اسقاط الحكومه والمطلب تغيير
رئيس الى اخره بتلاقي بعد كده بعض العناصر
بتاخذ الحشود الى ضرب البنيه التحتيه الى
ضربه اهدافنا
العمليه الحقيقه هو تدمير الدوله عندنا
العنصر الثالث
وبالتالي طبعا كان اختفى التغيير الى صالح
والعنصر الثالث قريب من العنصر الثاني هو
عمليه ال ال حث المستمر على الحشد في
الشارع علشان يعمل عمليات التاخير التغيير
وعدت طبعا يختطف هذا التغيير لصالح لكن ا
عمليات الحشد في الشارع دائما تتصف بانه
هو مجرد ان ينزل الناس في الشارع لازم
يقتل عدد من المتظاهرين في ظروف خاصه
دائما بيكون المتهم الاول هو اجهزه الامن
للنظام القائم وبالتالي كان فيه سبب اضافي
الغضب المتظاهرين والاصطدام باجهزه الدوله
وقد بعد ذلك ان تكف عن ذلك تدخل دولي كما
حدث في ليبيا في سوريا او في اليمن عن
بناء العنصر الرابع الى رصد الدكتور هشام
هشام هو استخدام منظمات المجتمع المدني
لصالح العدو اه مشكل منظمات المجتمع
المدني ولكن بعضها والهدف انه يساعدوا في
القراءه المجتمع من الداخل واستخدام هذه
المعلومات على شان هذا العدو يقدر يفهم
المجتمع بشكل افضل وينظر يتوقع سلوكه
العنصر الخامس والاخير هو وضع الدوله
المستهدفه تحت ضغط مستمر الشائعات
بالتركيز على اخطاء واجهزتها المختلفه
سواءا الامنيه او غيره الامنيه هي باختصار
الحروب الجيل الرابع لكن الحقيقه انه
اه يعني اه حروب الجيل الرابع لما بنعرف
هكذا بتطرح علينا دائما عده اسئله هو مين
اللي بيعمل يعني هل الدوله
حرب عليها في حروب الجيل الرابع ب تصف بما
يعرف لدى العسكريين
استراتيجي او استراتيجيه القدم الخفيه زي
ما بيقول العسكريين وهي باختصار انك تبقى
عارف عدوه لكن مش قادر بسهوله انه هو الذي
يقف وراء كل هذه العمليات الامر الاخير
واللي بالنسبه لي انا خطير جدا انه لما
بنفهم هي ابعاد حروب الكل الرابع دائما
بيكون في مساحه طبيه من هو الصواب والخطا
يعني لما تيجي تاخذ حاجه زي السودان
المطالبين المتظاهرين بيطلبوا بمطالب
مشروع جدا والنظام بيعرف وضعها هو ب
يرفضها لانه خايف اللي موجودين في الميدان
دول يكونوا مدفوعين باجهزه
اجهزه مخابرات دول خارجيه
والمتظاهرين بيتهم المجلس العسكري هنا بان
متشبت بالسلطه
دائره يعني اليات حروب الجيل الرابع بتخلي
كل الطرف يشكك في نوايا الطرف الاخر تدخلي
دائما فيه مساحه ضبابيه ما تدري بسهوله من
هو الصائب ومن هو الخائن او من هو المخطئ
وهذا هو خطوره الجيل الرابع اشكركم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]